[Music]
how many of
you guys are pro masks i am the whole
room
i don't even i didn't know don't go
don't put me in a corner
i thought you just do it you literally
went into a corner i'll label myself pro
mask i'm so mad
i'm not pro-messed like the
[ __ ] crazy people for me i'm
just like i'm part of the team
so if we're wearing masks yeah i'm not
going whatever it takes i'm not saying
like mass should be the 45th amendment
or whatever amendment it is and then
like parade around
i'm concealed carry mass permits and
like i haven't even heard that position
i don't know neither have mine that's
what i'm like what is the crazy mess
well because like anytime you say pro
something it's immediately the needle is
boom the most extreme version there's
people online that are like i see like
my friends on my i
don't know why i'm my friends with you
anyway but they're like if i if i see
you out and you post something you're
not wearing a mask a block i'm like
uh yeah it's like i thought we're
friends what the [ __ ] that's what i mean
so pro anything i'm scared to say but i
wear masks
all the time and i whatever the law is i
do it all the time with the masks we
have a make out with masks on yep
really we have sex with masks i got a
blow job with the mask on it was very
safe
nice you had the mask on and the girl
didn't have a mask it was kind of like
the sports crossing
it's like the sports bra thing like
where the mask like held your dick a
little
tighter yeah it's like if this is the
mask then my dick goes like this and
it's like
i don't even need a condom it's safe
that is
you
yeah good for you man but then if if you
come then that kind of bleeds through
after like 33 seconds
bleep yeah so there's pro-mass people
and then there's also
anti-mask people see both of those the
needle is
giant yeah i'm kind of like right here
yeah or more towards the mask
i feel like it's also just for my
sanity's sake it's just it feels better
to just be kind of in the middle like i
need to just
you know watch myself in terms of like
when i should i'm asking that
when there's all these people that fight
for these rights and they're just like
so
fired up and then they have all these
things going on right
i'm always wondering like where
are the responsible pay my bills
pro people like like these because these
guys
that are doing it like when i'm looking
at them i'm like
yeah you got a lot of time like we're
responsible people that aren't shouting
through their window every chance they
have yeah i'm like
you because if you were busy taking care
of your family
you know paying the bills working all
that it takes so much time
you don't have time to [ __ ] sit there
all day and like [ __ ] on the internet
they probably think that that is them
taking care of their families like the
anti-mass people
they're viewing it as like you're not
going to take away my freedom freedoms
or my kids freedoms
so i'm going to make sure that you're
not enslaving me to a mess
so where does that extra time come
[ __ ] each other up because say the super
mass people
are saying some stuff that's so crazy
and they're like this is going to save
us and these people are like
no dude i can still smell your [ __ ]
bo through the mask
the [ __ ] virus can get through right
yeah so i'm not gonna wear it and it
goes through but then if they're just
people in the middle that weren't saying
[ __ ]
everyone would be like all right [ __ ]
if you want a mirror mask i'll wear a
mask
i just feel complicit in this situation
uh
people that don't say [ __ ] i'm not
saying [ __ ] i'm just wearing a mask and
like if people need me to wear a mask
until they say it's completely over i'll
still probably wear a mask a little bit
longer
just to for my own sake but it's just
like it's
it doesn't bother me it does it doesn't
i don't feel like i wear a mask
and feel like i'm in a communist country
yeah yeah i mean i just put the [ __ ] on
yeah that's true so uh reason why i
bring up the whole mask
stuff is that the anti-mask movement
has started to do a little something to
kind of
stick it back at the people that are
wanting old
masks and uh where are all these cities
because i don't want to live there
true orange county like ten are they
these guys
wait wait is it coming up are they these
guys are going like this i [ __ ] wear
my mask okay
pull up their shirt the holy mask it's
all
fishnet exactly so for example someone
wore
their uh paintball uh mask oh my god
around and they were saying
no one said [ __ ] to me no no one said
i was wrong there's no real regulations
to what an actual
mask appropriately should be they were
the kids going i'm not touching you yeah
yeah
i'm not touching you that's what joe
means by that where's the responsible
bill people
because this person has too much time on
their hands yeah i didn't know what that
meant
well you know what's crazy though this
guy had a lot of time to figure out that
the paintball mask was okay and he was
like i can i can also breathe through
this thing it's way better than the
stupid mask that everyone else is
wearing that's trying to abide by it and
he's basically making a point that it's
all about compliance rather than
about health and that they want us this
is a brainwashing
technique by the government uh now
there's
actual companies making masks out of
mesh and yarn and lace oh i love that
and they have no intention of protecting
anyone from covid
but it's mainly to make a statement
that's where joe would come in
joe would be like oh your anti-mask i
got the perfect mask for you oh you're
matt i got the perfect mask for you
sell the guns to both sides
that's what we've been doing for years
yeah because some people they're
they're seeing these lace masks that
don't protect you at all
but then like the pro mask people are
like exactly just put that over my
regular mask and make my mess cute and
it's like okay cool
that's a good way to do it it's just
funny that they're like
okay but it's just not protective
when you're wearing a mask yeah so
they're still they still end up wearing
the mask so it's kind of it's weird that
it kind of crosses out their own
agenda no because for them they can
breathe
true true you could breathe through
those so it's like i'm gonna do it
but my way yeah that's the thing that
like some stupid ass you don't know
even the pro mask people don't want to
wear a mask we're just doing it
temporarily
so we can all get over this [ __ ] yeah
cause we're actually
being considerate you [ __ ] yeah the
pro people don't go
i want to wear a mask forever you know
it's like it's just for right now
i don't believe in the no mask thing but
i went down the rabbit hole to see
why they are so adamant about it so
there is a school of thought of uh
there there is there is the whole um
slippery slope
argument of like if we start giving up
this
then what's next communism right so
there is a
but that's a slope that's like the most
that slope isn't even like
like you're getting us ready the slope's
not even that slippery though
so that's that's one school of thought
[ __ ] hyper speed slope yeah like
get away the [ __ ] over there that's like
an elon musk [ __ ] hyperloop tunnel
dude because i think the anti-masters
are like represented by so many
people who are arguing about different
things so they got that right
and then so there's a bunch of people
that look at them be like no that's
crazy like
what why i don't wear the mask is
because
the evidence of corona is inconclusive
and it's pointless and it's like
i don't have to do this and it's not by
law and
and there is and some people actually
believe there is no virus out there
and so when they're there they're like
um
you know so why should i comply because
i i i shouldn't
i shouldn't feed into the scare so what
they think is
is like this whole thing is happening
because it's to just scare
people and it's not really happening to
that extent i don't like
get that point because it's like okay
just wear it though it's like you're not
adding to anything you're not becoming
more like i don't put on a mask and now
just be like
oh [ __ ] i'm afraid i'm literally wearing
a mask for the old person that's at the
grocery store you know that's what
if you don't believe that that there's a
corona in the first place then it's like
why would you even wear a mask
you can believe that there's no corona
virus okay i'll give you that
there's no virus um just wear it
anywhere the fact that
everyone around you and businesses are
requiring for you to wear a mask just
because
of the fact that we're in the middle of
a pandemic whether you believe it or not
how the [ __ ] are you gonna be so selfish
and think that that's the hill you need
to die on
is i'm gonna cause the luckiest i'm
gonna make sure i get my ass arrested
because i don't want to wear a [ __ ]
mask
it's ridiculous you're finding the
person that's like not letting you into
the grocery store
because they need to stand for their
rights yeah and there's entire countries
that have been wearing masks even before
there was a pandemic in the first place
it's okay and then in i heard in europe
they don't even [ __ ] have to do it
anymore because they're done
no so it's like they
closed up did everything they're
supposed to do and then they're done
yeah i see like all these people from
europe like uh there's this girl i
follow on
uh from uh denmark right and they're
just out partying and doing everything
and the numbers are low
they're like almost done yeah here it's
like they're pottery and we just keep
going like crazy
well it's also the way they're they're
actually like writing down the numbers
apparently it's not
all that super accurate whatever just
[ __ ] wear a mask like just
calm down wear a mask that's true a lot
of people are saying like
like you know if you're gonna protest
against mask by wearing a mask that
isn't like
protective you're still doing it anyway
you're still doing this so might as well
wear a real mask
underneath and then put your protest
mask so like i don't like
basically it's like i don't care if it
says no
or i don't want to wear this mask or put
trump 2020 if you're a republican like
have another way of advertising you know
like even trump is wearing the [ __ ]
path
he [ __ ] up and wears it like this but
i can't breathe i can't wait for that
potus mask to be made first
you notice there's like that uh
president emblem on there
you wanted a mega mask
yeah you know what it feels like um i
thought that this pandemic would bring
us closer but it reminds
me not in america america is actually a
collection of little different countries
like the states are its own countries
but even within the states
like the counties orange county and l.a
it's like
yeah it's like the two polar opposite
world
so for those of you guys are local to
this area in la
it's like if you know if you're not
wearing a mask you're going to get
uh ostracized a liberal's going to beat
you up yeah or liberals going to come
over and beat you it's going to hurt but
it's
going to try uh and then in orange
county if you go there wearing a mask
a conservative's gonna shoot your ass
yeah exactly so it's like so bad oh my
god
kkk guy's gonna punch you in the face
he's gonna take his mask off
dude
this is this mask is for another purpose
[Laughter]
you see those two uh surfer guy they
have a character
uh and then they've been going around i
love their [ __ ] skits right and then
they're giving out free masks in
were huntington many freaking um kind of
like those you know like those beach bum
redneck dudes
that wanted to [ __ ] them up yeah damn
they're just asking they're just asking
like hey you guys want a master like no
get that [ __ ] away from me
like it's aids or something dude
huntington beach is [ __ ] aggressive
dude it's also beautiful too though it's
beautiful but i
i rather like be right there or seal
beach and like i don't know
peaceful it's peaceful you don't really
i really want to hear
what they are being said and like
how they're being so so passionately
convinced
that a mask is like the devil like how
it's interesting because like like what
joe was saying earlier like
people think people that are wearing
masks are
creating are fear-mongering we're
creating more fear and panic by wearing
the mask and
you know so they're not wearing the mask
so that you know they're saying
we're not afraid of this [ __ ] there is
no such thing as though and they
distrust the government yeah but the
problem with that though
how how passionate they are about it and
angry they're doing it i don't know
where
it almost feels like they're the ones
that are afraid because i feel like you
only act that way
that's very insecure yeah objection and
they're fearful of it more so than the
people wearing masks yeah but they sound
like they're fearful that their rights
are gonna
eventually like they're just it's a slow
grooming into finally taking away all
your i mean
so even if it's a slow grooming it's
like we can call [ __ ] out like if
they're like wear a mask i'm like
because if there's a virus going i'm
like okay it makes sense right
if they're like okay now you gotta hop
on one foot because uh
putting another shoe adds to global
warming i'd be like no that's stupid
but that's what they're saying is the is
the progression but it is gonna start
normal idiots think that's how it
happens
well because they're like hey you wanna
go to that concert you can't go to that
anymore you wanna go to these stores i'm
telling you you can't go anymore you
wanna travel
nope not letting you do that either you
know what i mean so for them they're
seeing it as damn you literally are
taking everything away from yeah
he's taking it all away from me to
understand how one community can all
just be on a different page you got to
see how they arrive to a conclusion
they're watching different media from us
it's almost like i mean
no [ __ ] cnn and fox it's two polar
opposites we're living in the same
country but if you watch
only fox or if you watch only cnn you
live in two different worlds yeah
and you're gonna constantly fight cause
you get different facts right
and
nothing is peaceful nothing is thought
provoking everything is emotional like
primal like
can you believe that they did this be
angry and it's like oh
[ __ ] i gotta get away from it [ __ ] cnn
and [ __ ] fox
true hello guys thank you guys so much
for watching all of our videos and i
know it's been a million years
in the making but we finally got just
kidding news
merch yup so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
you